this is Jose Ado Maas better known as
fito the leader of the powerful Los
cheros gang in Ecuador he was serving a
long sentence for murder drug
trafficking and organized crime in this
Maximum Security Prison in the poor city
of Gua
kill but on Sunday when soldiers raided
the center as part of a government
Crackdown authorities said he was
nowhere to be found the government
launched a major operation to recapture
him so far with no results
in an operation involving more than
3,000 people the prison has been raided
in search of the Most Wanted prisoner
and the operation
continues a notorious criminal suspected
of having played a role in the
assassination of presidential candidate
Fernando VI vieno last year fito has
often defied
authorities he has escaped prison before
and recently appeared in this music
video partly filmed inside the jail and
sunk by his daughter glorifying his
criminal
exploits following fito's Escape
incidents have been reported in several
prisons across the country inmates were
seen standing on roofs as they held
prison guards hostage inside threatening
them with
knives Mr President please reconsider
your decisions don't let yourself be
driven by impulses and false
expectations this is the first major
prison crisis for the Recently elected
president Daniel NOOA a banana Empire
hair with literal political experience
who took over in November promising to
reduce
violence on Monday he announced a TW
month's state of
emergency what we are seeing in the
country's prisons is the result of our
decision to confront them that is why
the government has taken actions that
will allow us to regain control of the
prisons that have been lost in recent
years
but some analysts say the president's
plan is
failing it seems like they are facing
the crisis repeating the same recipe of
the previous government it has been
proven that declaring the state of
emergency is not an efficient way to
contain crime homicides keep growing in
Ecuador and there is a risk that we will
remain the most violent country in Latin
America in
2024 in recent years Ecuador has been
living through an unprecedented security
crisis fueled by drug trafficking and
that authorities have failed to address
these latest developments seem to
suggest more troubles ahead Alexander
RTI Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aljer